le film les visiteurs a été le plus gros
carton de l'histoire du cinéma français
avec 12 millions de spectateurs après
bien sûr l'intouchable grande vadrouille
17 millions de spectateurs
trois ans après les visiteurs reviennent
le tournage vient de commencer en
bourgogne avec muriel robin jean reno et
christian clavier
reportage exclusif stéphane haumant
emmanuel bec
c'était en l'an de grâce qu'on 123 luis
escape et guerroyer bio lentement contre
son cousin le duc de normandie
cela fit rire la france entière en l'an
de grâce 1994
souvenez vous il y as jacquouille alias
christian clavier
le fidèle lac et du seigneur godefroy de
popincourt compte de montmirail
le français jean reno 12 millions de
spectateurs plus tard les visiteurs sont
de retour
une suite pour conter quoi cela mérite
dans qu'est ce tu ai raconté mon
histoire confidentielles le légendaire
raffinement du moyen-âge clavier a écrit
l'histoire avec le réalisateur jean
marie poiré normal de le mettre à la
question comment se passent les
retrouvailles avec les visiteurs
jacou y est vraiment une fripouille on
n'en saura pas plus enfin pour l'instant
fidèle à sa tradition le film mêle à
nouveau le présent et le passé beaucoup
de passes et grâce à un budget multiplié
par quatre l'essentiel du film se
passera donc cette fois ci au moyen-âge
aux côtés du séduisant jean reno
frénégonde sonnés mais pas changer de
tête
muriel robin remplace valérie lemercier
et retrouve son âme d'enfant
mes prières même déguisé quand j'étais
gamine est d'avoir les avis de
princesses et et c'est très très
d'élèves j'aime beaucoup ça je serais
une reine très facile vont donc c'est
une petite annonce urgence leur haine je
veux bien je postule
est ce que cette fois c'est vous tous
qui est dans le passé recherché jacquard
c'est quelque chose comme ça vous
verrons bien ça ne pas savoir ses
secrets monsieur genre le mystérieux
scénario du film est décidément un saint
graal inaccessible atteindront ceux qui
paieront leurs places de cinéma dans
quelques mois